thank you
[Music]
New York morgue attended
allegedly shared graphic and disturbing
autopsy photos and videos to her
Instagram and Tick Tock accounts all
people who work in morgues are creepy is
that what you're telling me yeah no
[__] way I didn't know is this a
two-story this is a new story
yeah it's from the Independent in the UK
okay maybe unpopular thought but can we
see some of these images
didn't give them to us but she she so
she is showing you like bodies right
autopsies all this stuff and she set
music in the background to it oh so it's
like extra creepy like a soundtrack like
put like work into it you're also not
allowed to do that right because you
can't listen to music in a mortuary that
is correct in a word she's creating
content bro oh I see is this is it she's
using the tick tock voice uh the magic
that was like your family member or
something like in the in a tick tock
found a dead body she's like Weekend at
Bernie's take a look and then she just
goes through this this one's got holes
in it
you guys know any Mortuary scientists no
way dude so what's that like a someone
who works at them someone who works at
morgue yeah the ones that cut people
open could that bird people to Cypress
Community College and then they have a
mortuary Sciences uh department so
there's a ton of people that are going
there for just that and a lot of them
are like cool ass Goths oh really yeah
and it's really fun because they you see
them hanging out you think it's like the
goth click but it's not those are the
mortuary signs I think you know you know
my theory on this is based on no
evidence at all is I think when you
start you're like normal you're like
like okay cool I can see myself working
at work and then after like years of
working there you become weird you
become a vampire you don't see sunlight
you become more pale you start putting
your nails well like because I think
they've shot I'm goth you shop at Hot
Topic even more God so they don't start
goth they become goth yeah not even goth
they come they become more numb to like
vampires would you say they're like
what's a vampire vampires is like a
creature
I think goth people look so cool but
they have to stay in their element like
they have to be in a Scottish Castle or
like they yeah
the part that bugs me because if they're
at like don't [__] turn into dust
yeah that's right yeah you're gonna live
near Stone I always do you gotta look
like you're a part of that world once I
see you in a line at a [__]
Chick-fil-A I'm like yo you look lame
bro you look so lame I can't see LED
lights on you look at that it's weird
because they're trying to stay in their
element but they most of them Drive
elements
nice why is that freaks you think
are they all from Kazakhstan bro I
really think what do you mean as extent
the goth people you haven't talked about
we took it to Transylvania yes how many
kazakhstani's do you know dude you know
people from Kazakhstan Romania bro
they're like Asian kazakhani people are
really good looking kind of understands
where the mummies are from Little Kazakh
Danny or like white and and Chinese yeah
they look beautiful they also kind of
have that like it's possible and like
like vampires cheap bunny like and
people man a lot of them fight in the
UFC and they're very good oh really yeah
there's a big population though there's
also a lot of lutherans there lutherans
yeah all right those are weird weird
bunch
more than the morgue people yeah I agree
when you're when you're a lot of golf
people like picking these death related
jobs because they're passionate about it
so I know a guy who served in the Iraq
War and he became a mortician afterward
and and he's he does it as like a coping
mechanism he's pretty self-aware
feels like he was responsible for so
many deaths that he should be a
caretaker for death that's a burden for
sure does he dress goth like does he
have those rings that are like claws I
don't know himself The Undertaker he has
rigs that are closed I know exactly what
he's talking about he does not he wears
leather bands around his wrist you know
those guys I barely know the guy oh I
know him kind of through someone and I
can't really say how I know him because
it's like kind of a secret yeah what
percentage do you think of like Mortuary
scientists or morticians or whatever you
call them are also necrophiliacs I think
about that at least once twice a day
I've always wondered that but the dudes
that I knew in school were more like
they had like a respect for it it wasn't
really like a kink to them South starts
guys are kind of wild though right like
if you saw like a big
fake titties like on a cadaver
you know and there's nowhere in the room
we all know what we did to Barbie dolls
and [__] right we all know oh my god oh
geez I mean are you telling me just
clean though this is what we're doing
enough to clean just in case
Colleen do you know you know what you
did to Ken we know what you did together
he's funneling titties I get it
yeah but there are fake titties on a
cadaver did you ever make Ken do the
splits checked under his board shorts
the context is definitely a little
different what do you mean I'm just
saying I'd probably be a little bit of a
groper okay it'll probably be hard
so it's probably not respect for the
dead I think it'll be hard
right
I'm sure there's guys that do it all the
time that's what I'm saying yeah like if
the titties not gonna be soft
orthodontists are doing it then but
maybe they're being are they is that an
epidemic thing maybe there's like being
filmed because there's a camera in the
room oh yeah what you do is you just
like you brush your elbow by it I just
make sure like your watches your watches
oh
oh my watch felon oh God look at the
camera I'm all thumbs today
pick up your watch right you think like
rigor mortis affects the breast though
yep that's why I think it's hard that's
why it'd probably be harder than normal
I imagine I feel like my mouse bad here
so I quite grope on this quite a bit
all right I'm out all right thank you
for your service
it's fun as well it's great totally uh
so the hospital officials ordered her to
delete the photos and videos from her
social media Pages before she left the
hospital which which an affidavit states
that she had appeared to do dude if
you're a more dude we don't know that
she could
if you if you work at a way it's in the
bin Now pictures of these bodies and
post on social media like there's no
absolutely
there's all unless you're doing a funny
quirky video
or yeah well that's like the nurses
remember the nurses during the surgery
nurses
those ones when they lose a patient
what's the morgue version of that dude
that is the Morgan version of that when
a patient comes back to life oh
so you go through mandatory training in
patient privacy they have a ban on cell
phones in the morgue they they don't
allow inappropriate social media posting
and the use of Hospital resources she
got fired uh because other staff members
raise the alarm about her social media
postings obviously like who does she
think she isn't going to find out
um is she goth
it says she's gone yeah what is her set
to say very gothy do you think
Renaissance Fair people fight with goth
people that's a good question some of
them are goth people oh they doubled
they double dip yeah no I think that
they all lived in the same era gut is
not relegated to his single Century
right no I think goth is modern but then
they adapt they basically culturally
appropriate Renaissance Sarah
Renaissance goth but then they're like
the dark version right because they're
like they're like the bad version of
depends if you're cyber goth Renaissance
Gothic architecture is really cool
Gothic font is great oh yeah yeah Gothic
Sans huh hmm you can sound pretty gothy
to me these are some gothy statements
when we go to the renfair though come on
guys dude we should go but dressed as
vampires it's in town isn't it see
because that's kind of tired that's time
specific right inappropriate yeah man it
sounds fair it's pretty fun guys I wanna
I thought we said we're gonna go we did
say did we say that in a video You're
Gonna Go it doesn't hang out at all
though you guys
are we gonna dress during the arrow we
have to yeah you it's better to or it's
disrespectful yeah where you have to you
don't have to but I mean if you don't
then you're weird what about Jesus let
me in as a samurai because it's like
during that time
no Sam hold on Musashi we do have to
role play that there
right that's what I thought I have to
role play that the whole time and you
can't speak English
okay yeah
yeah but it's role played racism is that
real it's not real oh it's okay
haven't that yet though they would they
would just be like what type of
character are you yeah it isn't like
that it's like hey sorry we don't have
any orange chicken or anything like that
and like I think the head orange chicken
they'd go prepare the Teriyaki for our
visitor from the East
they're like minus Teriyaki what is the
Opium yeah
don't they have turkey legs yeah because
I'm like they didn't even have turkeys
they didn't have turkeys in Europe
turkey legs are exclusively Asian
I don't have turkey I only see Asian
people eat turkey at Disneyland medieval
beer for some reason in Waikiki they
shut down the street and they do all
these like [__] food fairs and stuff
and then there was just like Southern
barbecue truck yeah there was this like
old school like Southern couple I don't
know where they're from like maybe
Alabama or whatever right they just they
have this massive truck with a big pit
just smoking [__] all this like meat
and then we got two big ass turkey legs
and it was so good yeah that would be
the ren Fair too man
they were black
hey you know what I like black goths
oh yeah you know what I reminds me of
Blade yeah yes blade yeah yeah yeah yeah
like that style looks pretty cool if
you're a day Walker being like working
at a morgue is a good job
if you're day Locker if you're like in
that Universe because then they have to
drain the blood anyway yeah I'm saying
you know what my favorite thing is
though is like when they can't afford
the style
they want to look like Matrix right but
what they ended up looking at is that
one guy that that you showed me yeah
the freaking hacker yeah Starbucks
hacker a Starbucks hacker with the neon
glow shoes yeah cyber goth is a pretty
cool movement too yeah you know those
guys are in the bridge they're freaking
oh yeah sick man like tracking like Joe
said like there's there's a budget
that's kind of necessary yeah because
otherwise you look like just one of
those guys who like in a Batman costume
who just looks like Batman lost like a
lot of weight yeah oh yeah yeah you need
you need an LEDs budget oh what about
the bad guys and all the old Batman
movies like uh like with uh George
Clooney and all Oh you mean with the
neon paint oh yeah that's kind of like
cyber punk-ish right kind of why'd you
look give me a look like I was wrong
what's the word for that he did yeah he
was like
those glow-in-the-dark gangs yeah yeah
yeah what was the dark game they were
though yeah because in Batman Forever
they had they're all good I thought they
were awesome they had Mohawks and [__]
idea but it took a lot of dedication
yeah whole thing well plus the police
can really find you pretty easy that's
true they're all just in this one area
too it's like ready to go it's like dude
they're in a neon area yeah yeah yeah I
illuminate
foreign